>>Narrator: Built in 1898, this brick
schoolhouse on the southwest side
of Chicago has seen
good times and bad.
>>Arne: Twenty years ago,
we were called the worst
school system in America.
I don't know whether
that was true or not,
but we definitely didn't have a
school system we could be proud of.
And we've come an extraordinarily
long way,
particularly since the
mayor took over in 1995.
And I absolutely am convinced that
where school becomes the true heart,
the true center of the
community, our students are going
to do extraordinarily well.
>>Narrator: One of Chicago's most
successful new initiatives began
in this old schoolhouse in 2003.
It's a pre-kindergarten through high
school learning community called
Spry, where test scores
are on the rise
and the graduation rate
hovers around 100 percent.
>>Student: I pledge to myself
to do only my best and to lead
by example for all of the rest.
>>Narrator: To alleviate overcrowding
and avoid conflict between younger
and older students, Spry
devised a unique schedule.
K-8 students start
the day at nine a.m.
and the high schoolers'
first class starts at eleven.
>>Tim: Okay, similes.
What is a simile?
>>Isamar: It's good, because
I'm not a morning person.
>>Tim: Get specific, you understand?
Go the extra step.
>>Narrator: High school students
put in a full eight-hour day,
and many participate in
afterschool programs.
They also attend sessions on Saturday
and throughout the summer in order
to graduate in just three years.
>>Isamar: I'm a sophomore, but
it's like we also call each other
"sophners" because in a different
school, we would actually be juniors.
We have to come during the summer.
I thought at first it was going
to drag, but it's gone by so fast.
It's like, I can't even believe
it that next year, you know,
I'm going to be a senior.
>>Tim: All right?
Again, the details
of pictures come in.
So Cora, which one did you use?
>>Cora: The room is crowded like
a mall on a Saturday afternoon.
>>Tim: Oh, the details.
>>Carlos: We aim for
100 percent graduation.
We have the highest expectations.
And our theme is that
the greatest influence
on the student is the family.
And the greatest influence on
the family is the community.
So it is very important to develop
a school to meet community needs.
>>Narrator: The school
takes advantage
of many community resources, like a
local hospital, where Isamar Martinez
and several of her classmates spend
three mornings a week as interns.
>>Tim: The internship is a very
special part of what the school is.
And it's important for
a number of reasons.
Number one, getting them out there.
Number two, giving
them the opportunity
to see what may be working
is all about and the kind
of difficulties you're going to face.
>>Arlyn: Put together discharge kit.
>>Arlyn: Right now, the students
are scheduled and assigned
in all different departments.
They work with information
systems, finance,
medical records, telecommunication.
And everybody enjoys having
the students here with us.
>>Isamar: [speaks Spanish]
>>Okay.
>>Isamar: I work with
the pediatricians.
And if I finish early, I get to
watch them do like everything,
like take the temperature.
And I like that because, I mean, not
that I don't have anything to do,
but I like the fact that I get to
watch them do what they do, you know?
>>Tim: Some kids, it's a success
from the get-go, and some kids,
they're going to fall
on their face sometimes
or not do what they're
supposed to do.
But I think that's why it's valuable.
I mean, I think you learn more
from your mistakes than you ever do
from just being successful
all the time.
>>Narrator: Some high schoolers
get to experience the successes
and failures of teaching, serving
as tutors for the elementary kids.
>>Claudia: If you see that they're
still struggling giving you a good
summary, ask them questions.
>>Claudia: It has been so helpful,
especially with the newcomers.
They enjoy it, because they're,
you know, they could relate to them
and they know they're language.
They're also bilingual.
>>Student: Who wants to keep
reading on the third paragraph?
Go on.
>>Claudia: And I've noticed that
as soon as they start working
with the high school kids,
you get more interaction,
you get more involvement,
so they enjoy it more.
>>Carlos: Sometimes when we
describe our model, some people ask,
"You're going to have high school
kids and elementary kids together?
That's not a good practice.
That's not safe, you know.
That's why we have
high schools separate."
Well, I think our work
is incomplete if we think
that after eighth grade,
well, we're done.
And then suddenly, they go elsewhere,
and many of them are not successful.
>>Student: And then choose one--
>>Carlos: We work with the
high school students saying
that you are role models
to the elementary children.
You represent what
they would like to be.
So there's an added degree to
personal responsibility to this.
>>Ana: Move this window
down over here, just for a--
>>Narrator: Another program
that links elementary
and high school studies is a national
afterschool program called Miracles,
which offers a project-based
curriculum
in an all-inclusive computer lab.
>>Ana: Miracles is a two-hour
program three times a week.
The students have access to
computer and they learn Word,
Excel, PhotoShop, Publisher.
And so that gives them an advantage,
as opposed to the other students
in their class who are
not members of Miracles.
>>Ana: So you do need to crop this.
>>Narrator: Designed to boost math,
reading, technology, and life skills,
Miracles requires students to commit
to a six-hour per week program
that begins in the sixth grade
and continues through high school.
Sixth grade students illustrate
the life skills they learn
by creating claymation movies.
>>Adrian: The first thing you have to
do is to draw it, so see how it looks
on the computer in Paint.
And then we get the clay for
it to be hard and steady.
So and then we move it, we
take more and more pictures
for it to look like a movie.
>>Narrator: This movie illustrates
the life skill, friendliness.
>>Adrian: So he's walking
and then he falls down.
And then he sees that he's
fallen, so he picks him up.
He is the person that helps
another person without asking.
So then that's a life skill.
>>Ana: How many pegs does it have?
>>Narrator: In seventh grade,
they build Lego robots.
>>Ana: Basically, I
just kind of watch
that they don't get sidetracked, or
that-- if I see that they're stuck,
just kind of guide them a little.
Because the beauty of this program
is that they can be creative with it.
>>Narrator: The Miracles lab
also serves the community
with adult literacy and computer
fundamentals classes offered
on Saturdays.
>>Student: [speaks Spanish]
>>Narrator: It's just one of the many
out-of-school time offerings at Spry.
By partnering with agencies like
the Boys and Girls Club directly
across the playground, Spry
offers everything from adult math
to computer science and salsa.
[music] Spry has become the
fulfillment of its principal's dream,
a community where learning
happens everywhere, all the time,
and everyone has a stake in it.
>>Carlos: This trilogy
of school, family,
and community is very important.
Because if you take a look at our
school and you see the potential
when they move to the local
church, to the Boys and Girls Club,
when they go to their homes, and the
message of education is reinforced,
then the opportunities
for success are greater.
I think it empowers us.
And we know it's extra work,
but we have to share the
work, and that's what counts.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org